all right let's go back to the phones
which are on fire
lots of people wanting to get on 6 1 7 8
3 0 47 50 is the number why don't we try
let's try our caller who the 305 area
code I'm doing it only because I think
that's Miami Beach and I would love to
get back to Miami Beach soon it or is
this caller from Miami
yeah North Miami Beach hey how are you
from city from Miami Beach but yeah
what's up I doing they were I love the
show man okay thank you oh cool
I'm sorry give me what I can do oh yeah
[Laughter]
all right they can be better now yeah
is it again okay cool sorry about that
right arm yeah I'm not a big
conspiratorial guy you know but there's
just there's something that's been kind
of gnawing at me for a little bit and
it's nothing crazy but um I don't know
if you recall when when Bernie went on
when he came on this ABC on ABC News and
he told you know well he launched the
campaign told him he was gonna yeah
who's gonna run for president how he
mentioned that he got criticized a lot
by his you know his his crew or whatever
you know lack ethnic diversity
yeah and that his BP was gonna be he
mentioned his BP was gonna be probably a
woman a woman of color and is that what
I saw I was sorry I want to make sure I
remember he said my VP will probably be
a woman of color I just don't remember
him saying that uh he didn't say that
verbatim I think but it was it was
something close to that I'd uh I'd get
fact check on that but I'm pretty
positive or something around those are
okay you know whatever I said that he
would you know love to look to a woman
for Vice Presidency or something like
that but doesn't matter let's we can we
can say it's something roughly like that
go on yeah roughly anybody was gonna be
younger than him something like that
yeah we checked me out fact that me but
it was something like that yeah I think
we can all agree like if it did say that
um I think Nina Turner is probably the
one getting groomed to be VP but my
little conspiracy theory I guess is um I
don't know there's something behind the
scenes where hey man tulsi pot probably
you don't know Burt because you know how
Bernie goes on the stage he's not able
to attack anybody I think a lot of
people on the left
you know I criticize him because of this
because he lacks like so much you know
he's gotta have a little bit more balls
when he goes after like you know Biden
and you know all the centrist and
everything with all my friend you're my
friend but you know whatever but I think
maybe possibly he might have toasty on
there they might have had a talk before
he launched said okay you know I'll give
you this spot but you know you got to go
out there and be my attack dog which is
what we've seen her do taken out Camilla
and what I've been waiting for and which
you know Tulsi kind of face-planted the
last debate was you know she's got to go
after Warren now and really take her out
at the knees for Bernie to really you
know be the number one and let Bernie
take out Biden let him take care of
Biden let her take off maybe Warren and
attack by them possibly let's go through
this through this piece by piece so
you're not the first person to bring up
the idea that Bernie has alluded to
Tulsi being his vice presidential
running mate I think it would be a
disaster but we don't that's not what
this phone call is about you know we're
talking about the merits of whether it's
likely to happen I don't have any
particular reason to think that that's
what Bernie's plan is nor do I have any
particular reason to say it's definitely
not Tulsi what you're bringing up has
been mentioned by others and it could be
where I think your analysis may go wrong
is if you look at the polling data
I don't know that Bernie wins by
attacking Biden because a lot of Biden
voters like Warren and I don't know that
Tulsi helps Bernie by attacking Warren
because a lot of Warren voters like
Biden so I think that there's so much
fluidity in those numbers that it the
strategy you're bringing up doesn't seem
to me like a clear winning strategy
obviously I thought that a lot of bite
and supporters like their second choice
will be burning so I think I think it'll
make sense for Bernie attack I'll bite
and am I mistaken by I mean let's take a
look right now as we're speaking if I
look at Biden supporters they're top
second true
is Warren and if you look at Warren
supporters their top second choice
it now has flipped it used to be Biden
it is Bernie now but only by a slight
margin so I mean you know I just don't
think the numbers necessarily bear out
what you're suggesting although it's
interesting but well I mean my kind of
second question to that was like do you
well you said Tulsi would be a disaster
but I mean if you were to run in the
general I think it will probably help
them as far as like her war right here's
one sensor I don't know that the math
warrants you know I think that is that
there's the qualitative idea that is
democratic than that I'm sorry what was
that I think that one percent that's
just a month amongst Democrats yes
that's absolutely true she may appeal to
more right-wingers than Bernie would and
you would have to run the numbers and
see if that makes sense that that maybe
there's something in that yeah do you
think it's solid like that Polly Nina
Turner will be as VP if you were to get
general you know I've not heard that
before at all you're the first person
I've heard mentioned that I have no idea
if that's something he would consider
yeah I mean cuz you see her on you know
she's on the stump from 24/7 yeah I mean
I think she'll do great on the debate
stage she would destroy and that would
be anyway okay I would be an interesting
debate you know my instinct is that
Bernie would go for someone who has held
maybe a different position I don't know
I mean maybe he would go for any new
Turner what do I know I have no idea but
it's an interesting idea always get
great to hear from folks in in Miami all
right